G1
[Música]
e
nos últimos anos Vimos um drástico
aumento nos mecanismos que disseminam
notícias falsas pelo mundo segundo Uma
pesquisa realizada pelo a Vaz pelo menos
noventa e oito por cento dos eleitores
do presidente eleito em 2018 foram
submetidos a notícias falsas pelo menos
noventa porcento deles acreditou em
alguma dessas afirmações alguns anos
antes em 2017 eu tomei uma decisão que
mudaria completamente a minha vida
e eu creio uma conta no Twitter um
perfil anônimo com o objetivo de fazer
alguns questionamentos sobre os
discursos fantasiosos do
empreendedorismo de lá para cá
muita coisa mudou
e assim como vários outros brasileiros
Eu também acreditava que poderia montar
um negócio e mudar minha vida Eu também
acreditava que conseguiria ganhar um
dinheiro no caminho e fazer a diferença
no mundo quanto mais eu tentava fazer um
negócio dá certo mas ficava claro que
alguns detalhes estavam fora dos livros
de empreendedorismo e vídeos na internet
a missão da minha vida se tornou esse
por mentiras mecanismos de Notícias
falsas e essas promessas fantasiosas
Oi mas como é possível fazer isso como é
possível desafiar pessoas famosas
pessoas muito ricas pessoas grandes sem
que ninguém saiba quem eu sou como eu
consigo fazer isso preservando a minha
identidade e é preciso confessar que a
conta começou com um leve tom de humor a
ideia Inicial era ser um pouco engraçado
mas
rapidamente eu sentia necessidade de
passar uma mensagem mais séria mais
profunda eu senti a necessidade de que
as pessoas confiassem em mim e não fácil
fazer isso sendo anônimo Quando foi a
última vez que você deu ouvidos a um
estranho ao longo de 10 anos produzindo
conteúdo para internet eu descobri que
existem apenas dois atributos
necessários para conquistar uma
audiência
É verdade e valor quando você diz a
verdade e essa verdade vem carregada por
um valor às pessoas param ouvem e
escutam que você tem para dizer uma das
maiores descobertas da humanidade foi o
desenvolvimento do método científico
o método científico
ele proporciona a possibilidade de pegar
uma afirmação de pegar uma descoberta e
revisar repetir questionar
é preciso para o método científico
que a pessoa que fez a descoberta seja
completamente diz considerada Esse
princípio de impessoalidade é tão
importante por método científico que a
sociedade real de ciência Tem como lema
os dizeres nullius in verba ou do latim
nas palavras de ninguém Esse princípio
de intencionalidade de impessoalidade
faz com que a gente consiga olhar hoje
tanto tempo de e as descobertas de
Newton reproduzir confirmar e apaixonar
o que não estiver certo um dos grandes
passos que eu tive como autor do Startup
da real foi essa possibilidade de olhar
para dados científicos para informações
e para estatísticas funcionando Cada
notícia falsa cada informação incorreta
cada mentira cada afirmação fantasia
rosa e essa é a grande força que faz com
que as pessoas Ouçam o que o perfil tem
para dizer
é mas não é só utilizando a verdade que
você convence as pessoas muitas vezes as
pessoas querem acreditar nas mentiras as
pessoas querem acreditar nas notícias
falsas e eu preciso um pouco mais do que
simplesmente jogar fatos para que as
pessoas passem ouvir que muitas vezes
elas acreditam que Essas mentiras vão
fornecer para elas a chance de futuro
melhor a crença de que o futuro pode ser
melhor mas existe um passo que é
fundamental na hora de conseguir
convencer essas pessoas
sabe quando você tá conversando com
alguém está no mesmo de uma discussão e
nem ouvir mais o argumento que a outra
pessoa tem para te apresentar você
começa a repetir as próprias respostas
na sua cabeça Isso se chama o efeito
Esse é um efeito chamado de Black Fire
effect é um vez cognitivo onde a um ser
é você passa a em forçar ainda
mais as suas crianças vão quebrar esse
feito eu sugiro um método muito
eficiente
O primeiro é mostrar para outra pessoa
que vocês estão do mesmo lado que vocês
defendem a mesma ideia o segundo é
apresentar um contexto um personagem e
um sentimento
bom então quando alguém é exposto a uma
pirâmide financeira por exemplo não
adianta falar para essa pessoa que as
possibilidades matemáticas são
impossíveis para aquele negócio dá certo
mas se eu construir um contexto
trouxeram personagem e encaixar um
sentimento Uma emoção eu posso explicar
com muita clareza Aonde está o problema
então lembram da pirâmide financeira Eu
tenho um primo e esse primo uma vez foi
abordado por alguns amigos esses homens
ofereceram uma ideia de negócio bastava
comprar alguns produtos se cadastrar e
cadastrar outras pessoas abaixo dele a
lógica funcionaria da seguinte forma as
pessoas abaixo vender em um produto
também ele vender e o produto tem um
lucro todos os ganhos dessas pessoas
abaixo dele um percentual viria para ele
Ele ficaria rico trabalhando cada vez
menos por quanto mais pessoas tivessem
abaixo dele na teoria A ideia é muito
boa parece que É
mas o resultado disso Depois de alguns
meses
foram produtos encalhados um emprego
perdido em um casamento terminado porque
ele usou a poupança o sou todas as
reservas para investir num negócio que
não teria nenhuma chance de dar certo
contando Assim fica mais fácil entender
Onde está o erro fica mais fácil
entender as consequências do erro é
muito mais fácil do que simplesmente
colecionar algo que está acontecendo
porque quando você cria um contexto a
história e os fatos funcionam como fios
Condutores da Verdade quatro anos se
passaram desde que eu creio Startup da
real de lá para cá outros inúmeros
perfis surgiram com a mesma Proposta com
ideias similares em nichos separados
esse movimento fez com que a sociedade
fez com que as pessoas fizessem com quem
fala para o público se tornasse um pouco
mais e pelas mentiras que disseminam mas
o Brasil vai passar por um novo ciclo
eleitoral
e os mecanismos de Notícias falsas não
vão parar eles tendem a se fortalecer
nos próximos anos e eu sei que a gente
não consegue mudar o mundo sozinho
é mas individualmente falando com cada
uma das pessoas a gente pode fazer a
diferença e quando você faz isso da
forma certa ninguém perde tempo
perguntando quem você é muito gato
E aí